hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now we're in a
new area where everything seems to be
owned horribly horribly wrong which is
kind of a common theme in this game
but I think my oh hey how's it going
hello
what's that ID tag say Oh No
are you Alice oh I think that's Juan's
girlfriend Brandon's girlfriend Oh No
whoa that's so weird
so basically the humans that were
captured we're basically just Oh what
would this do can I use this
I saw something oh here we go hey
flibbidee doo da flippidy bluh bluh
maybe the boom no I can't even integrate
Catherine so I'm guessing those things
they grab the humans and then integrated
them into the system and somehow they
had their bodies taken over and I guess
I guess what I imagine is happening with
these people is that they've been
forcibly forcibly integrated into the
Wow like the program the wau is trying
to get humans onto the ark and this is
how it's doing you it's just shoving
them in here keeping them alive but
putting their minds and stasis that's
what happened when I went into in the
last episode when I went into that
memory there or fake memory or prequel
that was that was the computer trying to
get me into the world oh my goodness
holy crap which is probably why Brandon
whoa oh that's a thing
hello which is probably why Brandon Wow
you are weird look like something
straight out of Silent Hill which is
probably why Brandon wasn't ever
integrated after he killed himself
because his brain died before the thing
could get to him so it couldn't
integrate him oh god I shouldn't oh I
thought the window was over there for a
second okay okay so here's the situation
I'm running away from a diabolical
monstrosity that thinks I'm a machine
and it wants her I'm a human and it
wants to shove me into the computer but
I'm actually not a human I'm still not
and I don't think I fit am I supposed to
be able to crawl under there or some I
don't know so I got to find a way to get
around here but why did it come through
here why did it send me here what what's
the deal did not send me here was a
hospital to come this way
there was no other way for me to go yeah
I was kind of cutting off my escape oh
he wouldn't come this way I have no way
to get away from him I should hide I
don't exactly know what I'm supposed to
be doing right now because I I don't
want to run straight into it but I've
got no other way to go I can't see a
thing either it's totally dark if you
guys can't see anything don't worry I
can't either
I mean I could turn on my flashlight but
frankly I don't want to right now
somehow I think that would be bad for my
health okay
I think he's just he might just be
looping in this area which means that I
should be able to get around him somehow
hopefully don't mind me
carry on oh I think he's down there
well yeah he's definitely done there
okay so if he's just making a looping
path that should mean that I should be
able to like walk around him oh oh where
is he is he coming back oh he's coming
back
okay I'm not gonna look at you I'm gonna
be fine oh god I'm not gonna be okay it
worked for the other guy why wouldn't it
work for this guy
I'm hearing the whispers of the dead at
the moment where is he
what is that sound anyway I really wish
I could get a bead on him I just can't
seem to can't seem to get around this
guy I'm kind of just scared to go around
him mostly just cuz I think he's gonna
kill me at any moment that was loud
happy about that one where am I now I'm
in a dead end again again another
goddamn dead end
it's a hiding place I guess ah Rick Rick
I really don't know what it wants from
me
I think this is a different monster than
the last one
whoa I don't think I don't think this
one can hear the doors it's very slow
moving and hey what is that Bing bong
okay closer oh god damn it don't do that
to me okay
well that's no that's
okay okay okay all right safety may be
safe in the vents
okay close that up I didn't need to heal
it didn't actually hit me so I think I'm
okay on that front
okay that was stressful man this game is
gonna take me forever it keeps taking me
ten minutes to go ten feet Jesus
this is not okay because I knew it was
gonna come obviously frictional games
they're gonna make a terrifying
experience I'm just gonna be surrounded
by death at all times have to slowly
incrementally inch my way forward and
hope that I do not die that's the only
hope that I have in this dark dark
corner of the world where does this go
if this just leads back to where I was
and I didn't find this path I'm gonna be
very oh oh man this is a lot of growth
oh okay this is another dead end why do
I keep going the way of the dead ends
what good does this do me oh but the
good it does me as it loops me around Oh
this one doesn't seem very fast but I
think it responds to sight more than it
responds to sound okay so that actually
might have benefitted me a lot nope
nevermind it's still over here Oh God
okay I can't even see it oh I can see it
now it's big black and very lumbering
okay oh god it's so weird oh it's so
weird it's coming back okay oh I've just
been like I've been at my wit's end this
entire office I've been going so slowly
but I've just been in this eternal panic
state uh I just want to relax damn it
give me a breather give me some damn
slack oh god he just went through the
door that I need to go through Oh piss
oh come on it's no good for me
is it where is it Oh God's come back
[ __ ]
yes jetski all right this is a dead end
but it's a hidey hole just go right on
by just go right on by
there you are beautiful huh you're so
lesson pretty with you
weird cylindrical hoof eatin big bulbous
blobby body kind of undulates and flops
all over the place I don't much care for
it in fact I think it's terrible
no offense actually all of the offense
every offense I can possibly make that's
what I think of you and also screw your
mother I'm gonna do this just in case
cuz I don't know if I got damaged hey my
god
okay all about her all about her all
better baby yeah that's probably a dead
end he's probably right behind me okay
all bright and shiny I wonder when this
is gonna go out is it is do I need to go
in that vendor versus another dead end I
needed to go in that vent
oh [ __ ] you Oh go go open oh but now
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
need to stop going to all the dead ends
because I'm not good at picking out
where I need to go whoo
please tell me it can't follow me in the
vents because that would not be good at
this point I'm not very happy about the
situation that I'm in it would really
suck if I got to the end of this hallway
there was just a tendon
whoa hi oh boy yeah geez where am i knit
something something tells me that it
might be able to slide it's weird Oh God
is it coming through there coming
through there isn't it yeah yep
it's come through there okay so it's
gonna make one pass down this loop one
way or another
which way is gonna go Oh so lumbering oh
it's so lumber ramen during which way
it's gonna go this way okay
Oh what no oh oh God
well what is it doing oh it's so weird
oh it's so weird oh it's so weird and
unnatural the way it moves I don't have
anything to throw to distract it do I
got to follow it in is that what I gots
to do probably oh that's not good okay
but I can tuck in here ba okay I'm all
good in this neighborhood oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy
homina homina homina homina whoo no you
do not no no no no you shut your mouth
there I don't want to talk to you I
don't want to look at you I don't want
to see you the only thing I'll accept
will be hearing you slip and slop and
thump your way out that door damn it
why aren't you slipping in slumming - no
okay he's slipping and slumping he's a
slippy slump err he's a slump II won't
be Wampus slough oh god damn it don't
tell me I got a progressively make my
way farther up this oh I do oh crap
what was that oh oh okay why did he do
that
this doesn't make any damn sense okay so
this says power failure recharge service
battery okay so oh I'm dead
I'm dead I'm right in plain view I'm not
gonna look at ya
that's how I'm gonna survive this
encounter I think positive thoughts I
got some rainbows in my brain I'm dead
oh no legate I don't have to acknowledge
you isn't that correct
I'm gonna run now okay please somehow
didn't die I probably should have closed
that door that would have been the
intelligent thing to do but I'm not very
intelligent then that time oh I'm just
going in as a girl oh look at me
everything's all a jittery am i dead
is this what death feels like maybe I
should have jumped in there maybe I
should have done something other than
everything that I did up until that
point I really do wonder if like the the
half body that I got in me is where was
I supposed why why did I go down here is
it like there was no point to come down
this way it was just a death trap that's
all it was a big fat red herring it's
like no way to get down is there I just
want to get down and jiggy with it oh
man
I really don't know what it wants me to
do it's gotta be something in this area
I need to find a Healy place I mean it
looks like there's a pathway down but I
don't know oh I see okay so this
ordinarily would but it's all chained up
so I should there should be a way to get
down somewhere cuz why wouldn't there be
oh oh oh I just needed to open up the
panel and pump the young I needed to
pump it up nice and hot and heavy I
didn't know that was what was required
of me how would I have known there was
nothing really indicating though that
was what I needed and how was I to know
that the battery was going to be charged
by my epic hand job skills didn't you
know I'm a pleasure bot beep boop here
to service your every needs now get the
hell out of here so I can get to the
goddamn door you [ __ ] big walking mud
hole where are you I don't know where he
is
I need some health I need some health
very badly I need to find a healy hole
or else I'm not gonna be going very far
from here
oh boy please tell me there's no water
monsters oh I can't swim I forgot I am
incapable of actually oh no oh no oh no
oh oh no oh no oh no no no no no oh no
oh no I got stuck oh no I got stuck oh
man I found the one place I couldn't go
I found the one locale I shouldn't have
gone my stupid flailing I Bhargav liar
professional game breaker have done
goofed and I done goofed big god damn it
there's no way to get out of this is old
wait wait whoa whoa whoa wait hang on
maybe OOP come on hey there we go okay
got it got it got it
damn it I am stupid
is there gonna be a water version of
that thing well I already know there's a
water version of that thing I met him he
was one of the first monsters that I met
so it should be understood that
somewhere in here there's going to be a
monster but I don't exactly know where
I'm supposed to go oh wait there's a lot
of right there never mind I know I saw
that in my flailing but I just didn't
acknowledge it in my brain okay here we
go
come on we got listen to me
use that Robo strength oh well isn't
this place pretty this game has been one
long heart attack one long extended
period of stress oh boy
what I like it I will admit I don't know
if I even said it yet but I really
really like this game I think it is well
done I think it is well made I am
thoroughly enjoying myself and I think
it's got one of the most creative
stories that I've seen thus far
we'll see how it resolves because we
don't know you know you never know with
these things they could start good end
up bad you never know only why the
distance is all blurred like that okay I
don't think I can climb up that one that
would probably suck if I tried to jump
on the outside of that to get up there
but I'm stupid I did it okay
I did it okay I did it I did the thing
owner if there's gonna be a secret up
here probably not oh look it's a whole
lot of nothing oh I could have done this
at any moment but I wasn't supposed to
Wow good for me I wasted everybody's
time on a fruitless venture up a ladder
that I didn't need to go upon and now I
don't think I'll be able to get back to
the platform from whence I came
oh boy I am so glad that I do these
things to mob [ __ ] well that was great
glad I did that this is so much fun in
the way that I'm making everyone and mad
at me on the internet I'm so so happy
god damn it
okay where did there this okay oh god
that was startling why was that
startling either
I'm an adult I get to make choices on my
own and then I have to live with the
consequences
that's what being adult is all about oh
boy no second chances for me okay all
right let's go the way it probably
thinks I'm supposed to go and not the
stupid way that obviously I wasn't but I
wasn't supposed to go this way was I
whoops
well I done goofed once again okay okay
this way and up over the other way I am
gonna make progress in this game
eventually but in my own time at my own
pace which just so happens to be
glacially slow and filled with errors
and haunted by monsters okay how do I
get oh oh okay so how do they did that
um um um um this doesn't exactly help me
ah crap
maybe I got dropped down there grip oh
my ankles my Robo ankles pyro boba
ankles [ __ ] I wasn't supposed to go up
that way at all I wasn't supposed to do
anything you just saw nothing I did help
me in any oh no guess did okay I was
supposed to go this way I did it I did
it I did it I did it I did the thing I
did the thing else I did the thing no
get I did it
oh wow good for me
let me just shove me in that thing
that's a good old taste of health right
there I'll pep up your spirits okay
emergency flush okay fine I'm not gonna
read the warning on that
I think
oh okay I like how I'm breathing oh hi
hi friend how are you doing hmm
alrighty then let me just touch ya holy
[ __ ] hot vo to surplice her soon is
leaking [ __ ] it's bad real bad oh boy
okay so that's the thing was that Chun
talking but I thought Chun might have
been dead because she was crossed off
the list but maybe maybe maybe not who
knows I it's hard to tell from the
voices because there are a lot of people
in this okay so I got out of there
so that was good I guess maybe I don't
know possibly it's all very strange
very very strange and what is that oh
that's plinth so I got an achievement
that said I killed the dream I dreamed
let's find out let's do it me let's go
team of one I wonder if bubble BOTS
around here again why I sure do miss
bubble but I hope he comes back I don't
I'm not gonna hurt him I felt terrible
the last time I hope you understand that
and what are these things
I remember seeing in a video early on in
the game about how oh these are the
underwater power generators but for some
reason they're not generating any power
I wonder why
Oh oh you're not bubble bud you're
something else you're the other one
you're the other type but you don't seem
to be very functional so I'm gonna let
you rest and hopefully bubble butts
around here oh oh no oh oh oh no that's
just another one of those things yeah
okay
I was almost worried for a second but I
don't have any feelings towards you okay
there's another Healy who there but I
don't know if I need it but I'll use it
anyway just in case cuz people people
that say that I needed to use these a
lot also I wanted to mention this a
couple episodes ago but I kind of forgot
about it and kept I kept in the back of
my mind in my queue when I ever I have
things to say I always queue them up
they're like I need to say that after I
get through the situation and something
horrible happens and I forget all about
it
but I meant to say that someone in the
comments had an interesting point wait
oh [ __ ] open and nobody's answered to
anything
look I cold-hearted [ __ ] what
his name is out here to die don't you
get it they're dead they're all dead
yeah you're right how can you be so calm
about this [ __ ] we are dying how much I
have you guys gone 20 minutes tops hey
I'm in a red seconds away before the co2
gets me rusty why wait right I'm the
master of my own fate
wait stress what you do
damn drownings a bad way to go oh and I
imagine the pressure would actually get
to you before the the thing does because
down here at the bottom of the ocean the
pressures damn intense like wicked
intense so anyway what I was gonna say
and someone mentioned went back did I
dairy talk about this I have no idea let
me reiterate just in case I didn't but
um basically when I said that it was
kind of sad the thought of uh just
dripped drifting around for a long
period of time in space in the thing
with essentially a meaningless existence
and someone said like someone commented
either in a passing remark or or they
were serious about it I'm not sure which
a few people said it but it's like kind
of like we do now on our organic
spaceship that is earth and how we go
through and I wanted to comment about
that because like some people might say
that like the existence here is
pointless and stuff like that some
people could argue and that's another
philosophical debate and all that stuff
could be said one way or another however
if that that is the one thing that does
matter because this could all be a
simulation as well and it could like
life itself could be you know no one
really knows what the meaning of life is
because it's all up to everyone's
personal preference but my personal
philosophy about that is yes this may
all be fake yes it may not matter yes
the actions of the day may not influence
anything but the main thing that does
keep me going in that in that aspect is
in this life that we have I know that uh
someday I will die and I've accepted
that fact in many ways because I've been
confronted by and I've been confronted
by death many times not just me
personally but you know around me and
stuff like that so philosophically
speaking I'm totally okay with the fact
that I'm going to die someday and that's
perfectly fine some people don't take
meaning that but I do I take meaning in
the fact that I have this life and even
though what I do may or may not matter
in the long run where am I going
hissing safe okay all right I'll go back
then fine by me
I I don't want to be the brave one but
anyway I know that I'm gonna die and I
accept that fact but what keeps me going
in what I do is that I know there's
people other than me this is home hope
they saved me a diving suit
probably not but there are people other
than me and I know that there are
generations that are gonna come after me
so even though all that I have will one
day fade away into the blackness and I
will be forgotten somewhere along the
line I know for a fact that there going
to be other people who come after me so
I live my life for them what is this
[ __ ]
are you pocalypse Omicron is a
quarantine this is why they didn't
answer our call oh Christ rusty it's
called a radio they're not gonna hear
you better if you scream Kenzi you okay
look I know you're the strong silent
type but I need you to say something
every now and then so I know you're all
right Jonesy Jones [ __ ] sake let's try
the antics again maybe we can break it
we're losing Jonesy we need to get her
inside I'll borrow there's nothing we
can do for her right now hit the stasis
which and let's check the attics it's
kind of sad going through the chapter of
these people's last moments I don't know
how I'm interfacing with me that's
that's actually really interesting so
anyway what I was saying that like I
know there are gonna be generations that
follow me I know there's other people in
the world right now so even if this is
all meaningless it doesn't matter to me
because what is is and I choose to live
so that other people can be happy and
other people can find some joy in life
and other people can live better lives
and I choose to for my life so that
people that come after me will hopefully
live in a better world than the one that
I left so that's my personal philosophy
and though it may be meaningless the
reason I compare it to what happens in
the spaceship and why I say that is sad
because
they know there's absolutely nothing
else that's gonna come after them they
will never have children they'll never
have generations to come after them
there will never be new lives to come
after him even if they create artificial
intelligence that are basically babe
after that they also know that there's
an end to their world and there there
will be an end to the universe at some
point and that but for now I won't or I
acknowledge that that ID and I
acknowledge it but for now like I
weighed their path under there I will do
what I can for those that will come
after me and it's as simple as that that
make sense
probably not why not do a lot of people
but that's me so that's all I wanted to
say about that and hopefully I can
figure out with oh it's there's a big
blinking door right there how do I get
always the other one I picked the one
one that's not gonna get me to where I
need to go of course great good for me
I'm a smarty smooth here up Blanc Oh
door locked
how do I open it what do I do Oh do I go
down there weak okay
Hawking so here's ten earth Wow that is
far down into the abyss I kind of want
to jump down there there anything on
here that I need any important doodads
Oh looks like that one at the far end
might have something is that are those
whales is that the sound of whales man I
can't imagine how they built stuff down
here I would really love to know the
engineering behind getting all this
steel down here besides just dropping
into the ocean of course that's always
an option but I mean just like
structurally like all the support beams
and all the all the criss-crossing and
where it all leads to and where it all
goes that's really fascinating to me I
would love to know how they did I mean
obviously this is fakey fake and not a
real world but still still
gotta admire it it's cool who maybe I
can go over there I guess it could do
some leet parkour over there there's
nowhere to go over here somebody won
yeah yeah
whoop point okay yeah yep oh boy oh boy
okay here we go whoo
what and wink okay you're up uh-huh
uh-huh I see
uh-huh uh-huh I [ __ ] up yes I see
Oh judging by these steel beams and this
whole lot of nothing I got here
oh yeah I [ __ ] up okay all right got
it
conclusive scientific I done goofed I
don't even think the game developers
might have whoa wait a minute
ooh I don't know if I can make that jump
but I might be able to make it from the
other side rip whoa
ah it's
oh it's actually gonna go through it all
okey-dokey then
alrighty I'd I did I did the die I desk
I kept all over the place I was really
uncomfortable the way it made those
sounds work okay so I will end this
episode here and I'll pick it up when I
know exactly what I'm doing for the next
one but anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching continue for your
philosophical debate down in the
comments below and thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video I headed
this all in like eight hours straight I
couldn't stop all the time you know
everyone wants to know what my favorite
game was uh I think I like lean I put a
written warning good luck